Позов України проти Росії щодо порушення двох конвенцій -
про боротьбу з фінансуванням тероризму та про ліквідацію всіх форм расової дискримінації -
Міжнародний суд ООН у Гаазі розглядає вже кілька років.
Минулого тижня Гаазький суд підтвердив свою юрисдикцію у цій справі,
тож, феміда може перейти до розгляду справи по суті.
Це перемога верховенства права, тому що ми отримали чудовий результат
і можемо рухатися далі та надавати суду і світовій спільноті
факти стосовно порушень на українській землі.
А це означає, що Росія буде нести відповідальність і повинна буде надати своє бачення ситуації.
Заступниця міністра закордонних справ України з питань європейської інтеграції
оцінила результат розгляду як "повну перемогу" Києва.
Олена Зеркаль запевняє: Україна ґрунтовно підготувалася
й має великі шанси на перемогу в процесі.
Розгляд справи в Гаазі почався у січні 2017 року,
коли Україна звернулася до суду з проханням зобов'язати Росію припинити підтримувати
"озброєні групи, які вчиняють акти тероризму в Україні",
компенсувати збитки, пов'язані з катастрофою МН17
та низкою "терористичних актів", у причетності до яких Київ звинувачує Москву,
а також гарантувати повний захист усіх етнічних груп у Криму.
Багато експертів у зв'язку з цим зазначають,
що позов України став першим прецедентом,
коли суду ООН доводиться мати справу зі звинуваченнями цІлої держави
в підтримці тероризму.
Що загрожує Москві, якщо вона програє справу в Гаазі?
Вердикт Міжнародного суду ООН є остаточним і оскарженню не підлягає.
Якщо Росія програє, вона повинна буде виконати умови вердикту.
Якщо суд визнає, що Росія підтримує терористів на Сході України,
то Москва буде зобов’язана припинити фінансування
і підтримку збройних формувань у цьому регіоні.
Проте у суду доволі слабкі повноваження - це відзначають не лише німецькі експерти.
Передбачається, що держави будуть виконувати рішення суду
з поваги до його авторитету і відповідно до підписаних ними угод.
І, ясна річ: вердикти є обов'язковими до виконання.
Однак якщо якась держава відмовиться виконувати рішення Гаазького суду,
то в останнього, вважають фахівці, є не так багато можливостей якось на це вплинути.
У Хартії ООН прописано,
що в крайньому випадку Рада безпеки має право проcтежити за виконанням вердикту.
Але, по-перше, таких прецедентів ще не було,
а по-друге, важко уявити, щоб у подібній ситуації постійний член Ради Безпеки, яким є Росія,
не накладе на рішення Радбезу вето.
Тож, можна сказати, что меч у гаазької Феміди у цьому випадку тупий.
Остаточний вердикт Гаазький суд винесе лише за кілька років.
За прогнозами українських юристів, рішення буде орієнтовно у 2022 році.
І хоча у Феміди в даному випадку не так багато інструментів домогтися втілення свого вердикту,
вагу такого судового рішення не можна недооцінювати, зазначають оглядачі.
Адже Суд ООН - найвищий, найавторитетніший орган у системі міжнародних судів.
І перше рішення, яке доведе провину Росії, стане перемогою України на міжнародному фронті.